[Musique]
girafe crapaud pan ou encore lyon
entièrement réalisé à la main et
recouvertes de tissu ses oeuvres uniques
s'allume à la tombée de la nuit
touahri accueille le plus grand festival
de lanternes chinoises en france 36
artistes chinois de la ville de gombe
caïcos une tradition depuis des
centaines d'années de faire des
lanternes et maintenant avec la
technologie lauder de faire des
lanternes géantes
on a donc derrière moi et une
reconstitution du temple du ciel à
beijing qui fait dix sept mètres de haut
en face le château est mis en valeur
avec un spectacle de sons et lumières
avec toujours des éléments de la culture
chinoise présent fleurs dragon base ou
encore lanternes chinoises jouent
vraiment su associer donc
la chine et les animaux dont qui sont
propres à 3 remy imposer les animaux
auront une expression les curieux
peuvent assister à un spectacle de la
troupe de théâtre de sichuan
on y retrouve des équilibristes
acrobates et transformiste du visage
comme dans le théâtre traditionnel
chinois ils se produisent en face de
l'une des créatures phare de l'événement
un drag de 65 mètres de long le visiteur
peut ensuite continuer l'aventuré en
traversant la forêt remplie d'animaux
lumineux en spectacle de plus de 600
lantern répartis en 30 tableaux de jour
comme de nuit c'est magnifique quand on
voit le travail détaillé dessus on est
en paix on est bien c'est trop bien
tout au long du parcours d'un kilomètre
5 dans les jardins du château des
dizaines d'autres animaux tels et
volatiles zèbre ou encore iguane ces
animaux captent le regard des visiteurs
parfois venus de loin
c'est vraiment magique et magnifique
c'est une super belle expérience toute
une facette de la culture chinoise à
découvrir à thoiry pendant cinq mois
jusqu'au 10 mars
[Musique]